おすすめのアイスとがある雪見だいふく
もう
今日は弾みたちょっと振っノン ru 中
同開けです
ハイフォン一番心とだけど肇社長です皆
さんこんにちは今日か偵察に来てるんだ
けどもこの日課金という男あの全然休ま
なくて僕も心配してるんですよこの人あの
一世パンに行ってもずっと頑張ってるんで
今日このヒカキンさんがなんとかどうぞ
休めるよねちょっと僕頑張ってみたいと
思います絶対休ませるぞああ
先ファンっ
休みませんか
歩いて歩い
から
ブーツ
そのむかーし俺行ったような会えましたね
うん確かにやす坊安もっていう話をされた
と思うんですけども村のご存知かと思い
ますがそう僕は今年入って約3週間くらい
[音楽]
休止したぞ
年明け決定
正月から1月末くらいまで
そう結構ちゃんと休みますもちろんなんか
準備とか素材作ったりとか大仕事とか撮影
コラボとかもやってたんですけど基本的に
は本当に1回動画のこと
1日じゃあ結構今日はまだをしなかったら
みたいな日もあれ今日アニメ見て思ったら
みたいですよ
ありましてちょっと今日は
そのすすめ親分にしてみようかなとうわぁ
足で俺駅りさ今年見とけやはじめの都市や
で
お金宇宙バーとさあ作るために3週間デー
って思ったあの仕込んでると思ったんだ
けど今回はガチのやつです
でもいろいろ考えたらせたんですどういう
とかアーマーととろっかなとかいろんな
ことを考える時間ができたというそうなん
ですよねちょっと at 僕の周りの湯
千葉産見たときにやっぱりそので活動され
てるううう藪ちょっと大丈夫かというか c
[音楽]
ブーバーちっん疲れ等んだよ
30さん
web 33年間今年の4月で33で政権
35だからもうある方じゃないですか
ヒョッ中3点俺らって25羨むみたいな
阿蘇ですねそうだかと待ってるよなんか
ちょっとずつポケモンのレッドとさ
クリーン種だってさ今の子供たちぽかー
んっ
だからそういうのでズレたくないから俺も
ねアニメとか見なきゃいけないんだけど
やばいですよ決めつの a パー呪術回生
以下ゲームを1ミリもすべては何も一つも
混ぜカーン名を知らない全部ずっとどうか
だけやってるなんていう
バッハ
7います
全国このおいっに僕のヒーローアカデミー
やっててますオーナー年照弘あかん
アニメ動きまであるんですけど
全部見ましたグッチ前前略プロフ絵てませ
ん進撃も全部見てるもんねー真理教じゃ
ないからねっ
あれはみんな見ちゃったんだよ俺に切っ
そうだなぁ
ブービーよくちょっとシャベル
ブーブーもうちょっと喋ってほしいでもさ
ユーチューバー特有の休むつもりが体は
休めているのにチューブを見ると
ブーブーごめんねと路面なきゃっていう
現象が起きてたんでその休みの間は皆様
ですやっぱちょっとする際復旧力の種が
その際賛成とか
そうそうだからもう縁に動画出せば出す
ほどぬせる仕事ではあるからダメな指出し
た方がいいという感覚になっちゃって言っ
たもので1000万人言って僕はちょっと
結構リフレッシュできたなという感じです
ねああ
小山も1000万人ってもずっと頑張っ
てらっしゃるイメージがあるんでなんか
心体てきていうか心ですロココロ的に
ちょっとを進めているのかなって心配は
見せてみてパッドでれ北1金さんあーでも
ねーそれを落としたときの突かれる方が
ヤバそうって言うんだけど勇気あるよね
だってさあ始めてあんなにガーンてさん
しっかり自分から休むつって休んで久々に
挙げたじゃんとあれがさあ
福商伸びねえんだけどみたいになんかなる
んじゃないかみたいなさなかったけどやっ
すんな勇気っていうのはすごいありました
だけどそれってねユーチューバーだけじゃ
なくてタレントさんでもねちょっとじゃあ
一か月テレビなかったのかあの人9たなー
とか屋さんそうね言われそうとかでも案外
世間は思ってない俺ちなみ肇社長が3週間
ぐらい入っんどんんもう感じてないマジ
こんな逆に何か失礼な感じだけど普通あっ
て素敵見てるかな監修変わってもあれ遊ん
で休んでたみたいな
逆に視聴者さんからは高いっていうような
んですああ
これ俺予定ですかああぜひお願い一番我々
にとって大事なファンの方とか視聴者さん
が大丈夫ですか何かあったんですかうんで
3日も上がってないんで使うと言われる
のってだからくるんじゃあね人に言われる
あせるあせるなそう3週間休むって結構
言うか言わないかというとどっちでもいい
ラインな気がしてを言われた最近どうした
のっていうのをちゃんと
[音楽]
[笑い]
てょいらっしゃってちょっとありがたい
なぁと思っ
ちょっと長すぎたかな見てそうなんですよ
申し訳なさもちょっとありましたそうなん
だよねけど多分はじめシャツをのことを
なんとなく見たりとかするとやまさん
しようか村ねすみなんても92入んねえ
だろみたいなアラームもう九州はもう3
か月からじゃないですかね3回使ったかあ
さーん活動休止
ユーチューバーデブじゃんっその
[音楽]
ブーブーライト思うんですけどまぁ
ちょっと赤青白滑って1週間後くらいに
行こうフッカーサーッっきっちーちゃん
aegean youtube 九州の
ティングって難しい here on 当初
いつか俺行った時にシューッ
お前ってや投資です予選12年とは
めっちゃいい時はユーチューバーの吸収が
て言っていくよこれを破ったらそれは
じゃあ次動画えええ
をやると思う2000万人超えてるだろう
説得がありますか俺は3週
スケブ自分に合わせそれじゃないかパンツ
聞こえると動いてないなくて思われるなっ
てもらうとなるとでもね週間とかでねまあ
そうですね週4日間まんじゅう4日間を
開けないと休止にはなりませんシャ行って
10日くらいでフックした場合は休止詐欺
ですキュッだけだっ
果てに入ってだけです人それぞれ価値観が
ありますから来はずっと時に住んでみて
もういられなかったらどうしようみたいな
のもあったんですけど入ってよかったなっ
ていうの凶まあうちしてお役にずっと言い
に来ましたいっ
ん
俺は何を言われようと安前パパンのあの味
もうから直々
あげですからいたんです俺は羅臼もう
やめるぞ休んだらさだからあっちが向い
たら休んでみてくれそうですね
ハワイ行きてサポート帰ってきたんですよ
えってたからねぇでもちゃんとショーツ
とったからね素直可能迷子のカッター満ち
てこられた
ダート制度してなぁ
鬱とかについてもそう会議とかちゃんと
やったりだってサザン週間休止していた
けどさあの明日が明日があるある朝から
やる明日からやるアレイとかさあけっこう
これた撮影めっちゃ大変じゃ気概すぎ
だろうと思ってこれだけ三週間家作って
いうか皆様ですねそうなんですよだから
実質ね左中間休んでねちゃんと0なった方
の一週間くらいでしたそういう意味ででも
ほぼ一のは彼に使っちゃったみたいな
1000万円とサーブ盛り上がるんじゃ
なんか盛り上がりますねそこでなんか休ま
ないでもっと高い水準まで行きたいんだ
からなんか
[音楽]
w
急いでもかっこいいけどねあの人は
youtube で散っていったよ
それだけで親分は頑張るみたい
ご存じ頑張っていきますのであまりや証拠
のソユーチューバーが少ない時代に及ぶと
初めは頑張りますらぶらー
もう
わああぁぁ
ん
んがんぐんだった
aniがっていた